if this life is all you've got why would
you make it unpleasant why would you
make it difficult why would you make it
because there's something eating at your
soul
because because there's a worm inside
your body whittling you out from the
inside causing you to die a little bit
more every day you think you're gonna
die at age 90 no no that's the final
death
I told my grandfather I said there's a
last time you do everything and you
don't realize when that is
think about the last time you went
backpacking and actually slept out under
the stars for all I know that part of
you is already dead we are terrified of
being alienated from the tribe we are
terrified of standing out because as you
know
thousands of years ago that meant
certain death but we've been programmed
that way so I think what happens a lot
Eric is that a lot of the time people
are scared to be authentic people are
scared to say what they truly think and
feel people are scared to live the life
that they truly want because it would
mean in part that they risk alienation
from the tribe it's a really interesting
point let's assume that those fears are
reasonable valid and evolutionarily
based let's try a different fear they're
slightly less than 5 000 weeks in a life
think about that fear right one more
just went by
right come up with with a jar with like
5 000 sweets in it or something and just
take one out every week and watch the
odds that you're ever going to
accomplish anything or do anything or
Inspire somebody
you know go down and further and further
why don't you put it off another two
weeks or three weeks so why don't we
start this in September
that's right you know that's right yeah
that's the way that's the way and that's
how I think about it uh that's how I
think about it I take a lot of
inspiration from the fact that life is
finite a lot of inspiration
how old are you 40.
I take a lot of inspiration from that uh
because this is it right here and you
either make the most of it you don't
every day that's it and to me Eric part
of the reason why we had why we went
insane over covert and I use that word
accurately because we did go insane we
lost we lost something still
insane okay and I take your point but
the reason for me is because
we have lost we no longer accept the
fact that we are going to die we don't
talk about it it's a taboo in
particularly in Western Nations and you
see that with our celebrities with their
weird smooth plastic lizard faces right
because nobody wants to admit their
aging nobody wants to admit they're
getting older nobody wants to admit that
there is an end to this
so that being the case why would you
endure a moment of discomfort in this
life is this this is literally all you
have
is that Samurai I want to understand
this sorry say more I wanna so so why
would you if this is all we have if if
this life is all you've got why would
you make it unpleasant why would you
make it difficult why would you make it
because there's something eating at your
soul
because because there's a worm inside
your body whittling you out from the
inside causing you to die a little bit
more every day you think you're gonna
die at age 90 no no that's the final
death
I told my grandfather I said there's a
last time you do everything and you
don't realize when that is
you know I crossed the great Himalayan
range when I was 20 or something on foot
and I thought I would be doing it
regularly that may be the only time I
ever crossed the great Himalayan range
on foot my ankle Now isn't as good as it
used to be think about the last time uh
you went backpacking and actually slept
out under the stars for all I know that
part of you was already dead now figure
out how much death you can actually
handle in a living body
and figure out maybe you want to reclaim
some of that right maybe you want to
reclaim that through having children
maybe you want to reclaim that through
their eyes you take an ice cream cone
boy that ice cream cone looks good to
you you only have one of them you can
have you could feed it to your kid
you're going to taste that ice cream
cone so much more if you give it to your
kid
because his tea is just an ice cream
cone right there's a weird way in which
I just think that we're not equip we're
not figuring out how Grand this
adventure is and to your point about
covet
I don't even know how to talk about this
I could use some help there's a meaning
crisis the people who don't feel
comfortable talking about religion and
I'm not a religious person I'm an
atheist
the meaning of life has gone away you
can see an amazing band at a concert it
just doesn't mean what it used to mean
we have better guitarists right now than
we've ever had
and they don't mean as much as they
meant in the 70s when we were having
idiotic arguments whether Clapton Paige
or Hendricks was the greatest guitarist
of all time
I don't know what's going on with this
things are not attaching in the sense of
meaning
the greatest quote and I'm searching for
it everywhere somebody out there helped
me there was a woman in a doors
documentary who said the words back then
we didn't realize it was just music
I can't tell you how profound that was
to me the idea was she later realized it
was just music
for a period of time she was able to
attach that feeling of meaning of
transcendence of permanence of something
to something she was experiencing at the
Whiskey A Gogo on the Sunset Strip
we can't attach that feeling of meaning
almost at all there's something about
the phone that has rewired our brain we
call it a phone even though mostly we
don't call anybody on it we go back and
forth between a screen and a person's
screen and a person it rewires our minds
and in the end we can't feel our own
children or we can't remember our first
kiss I don't know what's going on with
that
foreign